okay all right for people who are
joining this livestream we are talking
about our packet system and making it
more user accessible so I commend the
positive
system for end-users yes build a packet
system repository website okay
and I mean isn't there a lot of stuff to
do how do you how do you push a packet
on to the packet servers right now
that's an internal process at the moment
yeah internal screws okay but and in
terms of revisions and so on you is
there revision control there or is it
just pushing a new revision it's it's
built by release engineering and then
it's tested by QA and if it's approved
they invoke the scripts to push that
life is a replacement if a packet is a
replacement for an existing pathway that
is it has all of the same you know
version number and open language version
restrictions and things and the old
Packer gets replaced by the new ones old
packets remain if they're don't you know
if I come over the new packet that has a
same name as an old one but has a
different wolfram version field then the
old packet sticks around what about new
version numbering of the paksas itself
original maker packets is handled by re
when they're built or by authors who
build their own I mean that's just did
the one journalist decent Pacolet for a
given Wolfman language version it's the
only one no that's not true we the
packet server serves people going back
to older versions of Mathematica so we
have packets that are only compatible
with no no I'm a given version there's
only one version of the packet that is
being served is that correct that's
almost always the case for a given
version yes although it's possible to
have a version that comes in two
variants but yes I'll say yes to that
question all right so packets can
deliver lots of different functionality
like they can install I mean so we've
had this rather
weird install menu item here
is it the case that pack let's install
any of these things
yes I could provide all essentially all
of those and more or what and yeah I
mean documentation for example okay and
what a Pacolet fundamentally does is to
install stuff into a user's and
end-users layout is that correct into a
not there at the mathematical layout but
a place in the you know a user
accessible part of the systems called
users called third dollar user base
access directory it's the bottom right
one in that big table it's under dollar
user base directory okay so for research
for documentation it's going there first
or what when you search for
documentation the tracker managers asked
to find documentation it does it goes
through various logic stuff but
whichever it finds you know it's all
done based on version numbers and things
like that so if I have a packet that
overrides some system documentation with
some newer version that that gets found
first search order in the sense that
everything is all looked at the same
time and the things that are more put
the most appropriate are then returned
so for a given body of functionality
there has to be a way you know if you
want to support a support upgrade in a
packet there has to be a way of
retargeting some path option that will
pick it up and typically when you look
at things that are packed with
upgradable verses things that are not
that's one big factor is you know
whether or not you know the pathing to
locate that functionality is first there
at all and second you know is it
settable at startup time
so wait a minute so the typical thing
then is that the main layout is changed
no no the main layout is not changed and
now in in fact the in modern operating
systems you must assume that you can't
touch the main layouts okay so okay all
right whether a question on our live
stream is question of how this will work
with github could a Pacolet be stored in
github and pulled in through the system
well oftentimes a PAC that goes through
a build process but yes in principle it
is possible to you know to you know to
create something where we could you know
maybe automates you know pull from
github and install as Pacolet if we have
a standardized build process but what
will be assets and guitarla can I put
something on the chat yeah your zoom
check this guy though I mean you can
install packets from a URL I think
that's the most important thing to stay
here in the sense that if you have a dot
packet file that you failed to expect
excellence then you can just drop that
right into github or any place you've
bought from cloud or whatever it doesn't
really matter as long as it's URL and
then you can right-click on that dot
type of thing you know
copy the hyperlink and use that as your
URL to use faculty install walk what
you're saying is somebody could put in
github a dot Pacolet file yeah so like
right click on that right click on that
backup thing yeah and then copy link
address and now in a new notebook just
this type you know excellent install
Open bracket
double quotes and then paste and
close everything up you know maybe not
fun to do that because it's an
experimental pack but so okay you're
gonna install it a bit walk and try it
just try it and I'm so so so get what
you're looking at is that github has
this release process whereby the you
know the owners or maintainer of a
repository can can build and push
releases and so on
John John yeah this is spinning its
beach ball this is a problem that I've
been seeing for a few weeks with version
12 it's just spinning here this look at
this look at this look at this what the
heck's going on there I don't know okay
so this has been happening to me for
about three or four weeks can I do
anything here to help you debug this I
took a screenshot oh no I understand
that but is there anything I can look at
here to help debug this nothing is
immediately coming to mind should I hit
abort
yeah they'll end up killing the kernel
likely the thing is that the aborted
antonyms the hell is hello that's
because we added Antechinus in version
12 and i need to remove it from my
Pacolet because that's where it came
from
at least idea came from there oh so that
was probably that's not gonna work
really that's not gonna work Stephen it
you just need to do prototypes as a
string there yeah just a prototype it's
the name of the Packard the first
argument of output yes
capital P prototypes just one word
prototypes that's the name of the packet
this is it with a private capital D okay
it's it's the dot
what filename without the dots backwards
and without the version basically okay
hey if they're if they install had
worked it would have given you a nice
way to fit yeah you can use a pack good
work no yeah you could use tobacco so
but he had to quit the kernel he quit
the crown yeah yeah incidentally what we
were seeing in this particular case it
looks like the hang that you were seeing
was in trying to generate the call stack
for the message interesting $2 abort a
thing you mean yes I'm dynamic in there
that that's what I'm saying it's the
call stack for the message oh okay okay
all right so um so wilmut if I want to
find out what packets I have what would
I do here right back let's find respond
all right Pope of nails Oh as a string
just use a little star it's a wild card
for I mean this is gonna be a lot of
tracklist okay so I mean all kinds of
junk so what are these things so I if I
wanted to okay fine I have no idea what
this is is that is that cached data of
some kind
well that's old-style data pack right
there I see so this is random stuff I've
had lying around forever yeah all those
ones are chemical data store now
container you got a punch in tour
starting here okay
all right okay um okay um okay Brian our
live stream comments that applications
that rely on behavior a particular
virginal packet may fail factors replace
twelve into existing Microsoft had a
similar problem that was called DLL hell
yeah yep it's possible it's possible for
this problem to rear Ted if you run
multiple versions of Mahara on the same
machine
no point being made is if you have a
dependency on a particular version of a
packet so look probably what should be
the case is that you should be either
able to say I want the latest version of
this packet whatever that is or I want
to burn in this particular version well
what we haven't do there what we haven't
really done up to this point and and
this is the the central issue of the oh
hell but but it hasn't hit us yet
because we haven't really tried to do
this is to express dependencies between
packets so you have packed what's a and
B both of which depend on pack let's see
but Pacolet a says it wants version 1.6
of pack will see and pack but B says it
for once version 1.7 installation of
package supports side-by-side
installation which is getting run I mean
if well yeah the most recent version
number that that has it matches the
requirements you know that has
requirements that matter it let's pull
back another issue here so right now our
packet system is completely open there's
no you know there's no authentication
there's no nothing
now you know I have to say that the
success of things like github suggests
that there's a lot of mileage from
things that are completely open it will
be much more difficult I mean it's a
whole different thing to build something
and that's where the marketplace stuff
comes in and so on to build something
where we can have private packets it's
at a fair statement
well so I mean I think the model to look
at is is NPM so NPM is the repository
for for JavaScript packets and
for you no I mean not packed you know
yes and and they have this free public
thing which people use it's incredibly
popular and you know most JavaScript
programmers or node.js programmers use
it but then they also have they sell
private NPM servers so that if you're
doing inside of a company you don't want
that javascript to be exposed elsewhere
you know it's it's your own yeah I
understand completely
okay but so what is our idea here would
this be another I mean in addition to
private clouds this is another thing
people could get as a private thing I I
think the NPM model is a reasonable
model right that model doesn't allow for
a yet different thing which is you know
right now in our cloud we have elaborate
access control where you can have an API
which certain people can be you know
permission to get and other people could
not be that's different in this case so
this is one of these things where either
you have access or you don't have access
well and so that's that's kind of you
know it's it's sort of the third kind of
you know
serving you know it's it's all public
and running on our servers it's all
private and running on your servers it's
private but it's running on our servers
on you know yeah well maybe that's case
we don't have to worry about right now
because that case is going to you know
we could do this by having PAC let's be
cloud objects for example right yes I
don't know what's that yes we could do
that just like you know you have this on
github where you're just copying the
Pacolet that could be a cloud object and
you could authenticate to get access to
the cloud object makes sense yeah right
yes
is there a problem with that what is the
Pacolet server I mean it's just a web
server that just has exposed certain
assets or what pretty much it's a very
simple thing and there's a little bit of
logic for what you know you request a
packet and it's possibly the packet you
get is different if it's a newer version
than the one you requested it will give
you a newer version but it does things
like logging and there's a little bit of
logic and extra stuff that is useful
like logging okay fine and we do keep
track of packet download so we can we
can use them for analytics and indexing
- I mean indexing is a major part of
this you know the PAC of the server has
to be able to see what's available what
the latest version of any given thing is
yes index it but it's a very small
amount of code okay so in principle the
packet server I mean I don't know
whether there's an efficiency issue or
anything else but the packet so it could
be the cloud is that true with an API
with just a pure you know the padlet API
in the cloud yes yeah I don't I don't
think it couldn't be
I think practically there'd be a
migration effort that would be
monumental doesn't because we have you
know decade-plus of packets
they're just files you just move the
files to another place so is there I
mean if you look at them individually
yes that's true but you know there's the
you know there's a server technology on
top of it which is not dramatic but it
needs to be efficient okay so what are
you guys telling me so are you telling
me let's look at the branches here okay
so one branch is okay one branch is
we're not going to do anything with
authentication with these things UI that
you know but nevertheless you're
proposing that we take this packet
server and we package it so that that's
something we can sell to users
yeah is that correct yeah I mean you
know I don't know how much money there
is to be made off such a thing but I
think if we build it right creating that
product will be low effort okay so so
long to say if we build the public thing
right then creating the you know the
effort is what I mean by that public
thing is not low effort but right right
once we have wise there's no I don't you
really have that oh it's like it's kinda
like doing the function repository
Steven there's a lot of coders there's a
whole front interface to it and there's
a lot of stuff that goes into this kind
of this kind of site we're not talking
about just a current Packard service
which were quiet little things that just
serve files we're talking about a site
that people could navigate to in a
browser and look it was their closet
okay so wait a minute that's the user
facing so why is it that I mean I just
think it's crazy to not use the
repository framework for that well fine
if I repository payment will work for
that then great we just just saying that
it's not I think it's worth it I think
it's what we should plan on cuz I think
otherwise that way with them were using
the cloud the presbytery framework is
all backed by the cloud and so yeah I
mean I think that's the right thing if
you say that we want exposure like
shingles and things we need the
repository framework yeah well and and
we have been talking about that okay all
right extensively yet but we have been
talking about that oh yeah fine
so okay so now let's talk about how
somebody builds let's just understand
the flow here so just like somebody
builds a resource object and most of the
building of resource objects is done
through you know things like build a
function repository item by you know why
was that so slow with this for example
right I'm making sense
yeah yeah by the way that font is wrong
still and that size is wrong still it
would be really good to get that fixed
okay yeah I mean I think I think that's
sort of a notebook GUI
for defining backless makes sense yeah I
think I think it's I think it's gonna be
different though because you know what's
a fundamental difference between packets
and most these other things is most
these other things you're you know
you're pulling up this form for the
purpose of submitting them and and
that's basically it
whereas a packet is something that you
develop and use on an ongoing basis on
your own system you don't need to deploy
a packet to use it know that all of
these other resources have that same one
it's not it's not only for submitting
for personal use say deploy locally I
mean computer for my cloud account
publicly in the cloud in this session
only difference between a packet that
someone can build and use on their own
and email to their friends and a
resource object that's been packaged up
with more metadata for distribution and
every time we make one of these it's a
new UX and new design Zoe yeah well
think about the common workflows wait
wait wait but bad sort of different
thing that he said okay so in this case
we are not supporting the following
functionality for the function
repository the idea of here's a function
it's been packaged up I'm going to send
it by email to my friend we're not
supporting that what we're supporting is
you push it for examples of the cloud
and then you send your friend a link to
that cloud you know URL and then they
can pull it down on their system II like
the the equivalent analogy I think is
you know for the function repository I
can type out a function into an email
and send it to someone no it doesn't
give you that's something
not great no it doesn't give you
everything it doesn't give you the
documentation it doesn't give you a
whole bunch of stuff right but functions
exist outside of the repository and I
similarly think that packets should
exist as first-class objects on their
own without having tied to contain them
inside a single notebook that would be a
disaster right yeah okay fine no I mean
another analog this is you know like the
cloud configuration notebook right yeah
the whole configuration of cloud isn't
you know the cloud is expanded like it's
just configuration yeah yeah I do think
so show me a packet manifest where is
where one what work go back to the web
browser know what vector does web
browser and then go click on prototypes
like right at the top there this one
here right no no no god no
all the way stop school witches are not
losing slightly ya know and then scroll
down a little bit then click on
prototypes folders the first one in
their list of yes there's a faculty info
dot M file but that's the key
manifesting right right right so that
manifest is there is all the versioning
that taught the scribes and the you know
what functions it provides and where the
documentation lives and yes things like
that what does that mean what does that
mean it's the main wattage of main type
of documentation main guide page or any
page is the thing that you'll get
directed to if you just type the Packard
name unadorned into the documentation
center it's just a way to say this is
what I want the user to see if they just
touch my pack with me into the dark
magicians I mean we don't have good
documentation tools but if we solve that
problem to know we're solving that
problem that's a separately being solved
problem Brian for that as well
so that's questions that run a large
stream that have to do with how do we
prevent malware how
we sign packets but that is something
that is going to have to be added but
there's there's nothing like that in
there now because everything is right
now being going through our release
engineering process and coming from our
servers right yes every now and then we
had a question from a user who's worried
about you know check sums checking
during a download just to make sure it's
no man-in-the-middle attack has given
them some bogus Pacolet and at the
moment we'd actually don't have anything
for that either
I think that's Kenneth if there's some
backlit file in the wild like the one
you know under like this prototypes
thing then you just have to trust you
know you just have to know if you
install it you have to trust it right
but you look at the code right so we
need some security some you know HTTPS
like I mean what is the actual protocol
by which we're transferring these things
they're down on just on the web just
HTTP and if we were using HTTPS wouldn't
we avoid the man in the middle
assistance
situation yeah so in terms of what the
pack itself actually does it's our
intention to create a system which may
not be a hundred percent foolproof but
which I think we can create a fairly
decent system for this that that will
basically you know automatically scan a
package and ensure that that package has
or Pacolet has no you know no
side-effects that you know that creates
symbols or run code outside of a given
namespace you know so you know so in the
packet repository world you will be
assigned a namespace which is going to
be some combination of your you know the
the name of the account that is
submitting the packets and then the name
of packet itself and you know within
that namespace you can define symbols
and those symbols of course might
you know really terrible code in them
you know whether it just be haze you
know whether it's just you know code
that does dumb stuff or code that does
dangerous stuff and and we're not
necessarily going to be you know
blocking that on a kind of automated
basis I don't think we can but what we
can do on an automated basis is prevent
you from doing things like you know Auto
running code you know on startup that
you know sends files okay writing plus
or something like that okay okay what
we've also talked about I think would be
good as having like a verified packet
system where you can you know submit
something to actually be go through
thorough testing you get a check mark
yeah it might not be free but I think
that's something that people would
respect okay but but the fact is okay so
I just want to remind people and also
folks on the live stream who are
interested in this the function
repository is our lightweight way of
doing these things Karl is mentioning
that there are lots of functions
orphaned functions lying around on
Mathematica Stack Exchange I'm sure
that's true and it would be wonderful if
somebody started to go through and
actually put those in the function
repository I mean so the function
repository is for function at a time
stuff the Packer repository is for big
heavyweight packages that have their own
that are going to introduce symbols that
are not I mean you know that the
function repository you know which is
already preliminary early life but you
know it contains all kinds of you know
all kinds of things here where any given
function is you can just see how would I
do this I just go here and I can use
that function just as a resource
function and now I could say something
like this oops
um and it will just work and that's the
kind of lightweight way of introducing
global functionality and packets are a
heavyweight way because what will happen
is presumably that most people will I
mean
okay people are mostly gonna be
autoloading padlets is that true or are
they going to be doing a needs like
thing for packets I think autoloading in
general is it's kind of evil I think
just we're doing our knees on that can
it'll be clear to be clear the packets
that we use today which are for system
functionality are essentially all loaded
I think if the auto loading is based on
it you know assist in a symbol in the
context that John described earlier but
but you know like for example you know
we have other packets which are
distributed internally you know docket
tools get length you know that kind of
thing which are not auto loaded into the
mess to install them I mean you know
I've said okay okay what you just said
is wrong I'm and it's not even answering
my my points okay my point isn't about
installation my point is about you know
how do you get to the functionality or
whether you call get or whether you open
a pallet or something like that which is
totally different from the installation
question fair enough but I mean what I
installation is pack light install you
know that's okay so when I go to my
doctor tools installer what is that for
well in this case packet update I think
it is but yeah yes the command is
actually executing is just pack let
updates off you know ducky tools with
the right server name and obviously in
order to make this a first-class citizen
you know we want first of all language
stuff that's going to be in the system
context that does this and second of all
you know a nice panel you know of that
allows you to kind of you know GUI your
way through this be nice to okay so I
mean to compare the function repository
with this this will be a thing where you
can have a
bored that says these packets are
enabled these ones are not enabled those
kinds of things is that correct and we
presumably would allow you to install
new ones and remove in the case of the
function repository you either call the
function you don't there's really
nothing to discuss about you know the
question of whether it's installed or
not it's all irrelevant well and and and
I think I think that your question is an
interesting one and not one that we've
really deeply discussed in any at least
than any discussion that I've been
involved in which is and this reflects
back to Todd's kind of you know gut
reaction that autoloading is evil but
you know if we know that everything it
you know is confined to its own context
do we want to compel people to add a get
or a needs command I think that's a fair
question
encourage at least yeah sorry might
encourage autoloading instead of
compelled well you know a bit clearer
autoloading I think is actually really
nice for if we tell people that they're
going to type you know my pack you know
my name space back pick function name
and if it Otto Louis based on a fully
qualified function name that's perfectly
fine when I talk about oh I'm talking my
people just typing in the short name and
expecting it so that's what we're doing
I mean in the in the function repository
the way we're doing it is you know
string names and a global namespace
basically well we register where people
have to register their names now the
alternative to this is to how do I get
the UUID for this I guess I can just say
here resource is a second argument in
research function or you can go see the
resource object you know what's the
second argument UUID all caps okay so to
be clear that's what the function really
is and this is just its short name right
and and so in the URL this is ultimately
a URL right so if I say resource object
if I if I were to say I think I think
just saying we saw subjective noun queue
right would give me that resource object
yeah
nice very nice and there's where it
actually is okay all right
by the way or not on our live stream
Brian is talking about the Assembly
strong name of dotnet I think strong
names are I'm guessing that they're the
same kind of thing as you're saying a
fully-qualified that this full of
qualified name idea is that right Frank
strong name is a is a they sort of like
a sign thing as well it fired up a code
signing so it's more like the security
thing John was talking about where we
have you know signed packets that are
known to have you know there was that
interesting like all recently of having
code named by its hash and I wonder if
they're having I mean that's it's
effectively another form of content
addressability yes
I mean if it's if it's code name by its
hash then that gives you effectively
signing as well yeah but but it doesn't
nicely deal with the problem of upgrades
I agree
all right okay so let's let's case I
mean that you know the general point is
that you know my view has been that you
know if we are composing the namespace
from the username and the packet name
you know then we make you know certain
classes of problems go away you know
such as you know people oh you know
spamming things based on a kind of typo
like my username right doesn't you know
it's not a symbol name that just doesn't
happen to work I mean it's you know it's
got him we could use publisher in it
well I mean I said composed from I mean
you know if there's you know a one to
one way
map whatever legal user names are to
legal and you know to legal namespace
names then we have this publisher system
that we've made part of the repositories
that would be perfect for this fair
enough but it's gonna be an obscure UID
isn't it know that publishers have you
know pretty names that are unique and we
do I have a publisher ID for example in
12 1 metal resolve to your default thing
but you have access to one called
Wolfram that does other people at the
company have access to you know some
many to many you can have access to
multiple publish rate these multiple
people can have access to one publisher
ID all right okay fine so that so that's
a way what you're describing there is a
way of using our contact system okay so
the autoload constant it is just a
meeting where we start putting our dips
down for one letter publisher IDs I
program you know this is one of those
fortunate things the registration of
names is one of those things where one
learns that the world is actually finite
the number of people who want you know
otherwise none of those things that
involve registering names would never
work yeah but only one person will be
able to get you know Susan K right the
first Susan K will get Susan K but we
since we have a human looking at it only
NASA is gonna get NASA yeah right well
that's right yes I could tell a big hard
luck story in 1976 when I got my first
login on a computer system that was a
you know an interactive computer system
I really wanted to get SW and that was
already taken and was the system on the
ARPANET um so I got s wolf I finally met
many many years later the woman who had
got s WS as her username on that system
anyway silly story um so for many many
years wolf was my um okay ironically it
wasn't even her name that's W some
random letters
no I think there was they um
anyway the okay
but but so what you're proposing then is
so for example that that there be
something that says something like you
know Pacolet backtick J back tick Fuu
and that will you to reference that it
would auto load clear to me whether I
would you know requires something like
that Pacolet backtick in front of it but
but yeah I either the batter we're gonna
have to break that I mean we could we
could for example require all such
things faces be a lowercase fine well
okay never collide with anything that we
did so nobody might collide with other
users stuff and so and we can also use
something like resource Pacolet for name
you know and then a string of Pacolet
all right now you wouldn't need the
packet then you could just have J take
or call in Fuu right what are you
talking about we could have a sim
assistance symbol like resource Pacolet
that story makes it friendlier why would
that make it friendly because let me
kind of string name oh you can have
anything we want but that doesn't that
doesn't solve the problem of your
writing code and you just want to refer
to symbols in that packet by their fully
qualified names and expect that they'll
just be there see the thing that I don't
like is you know you have a piece of
code somewhere at the beginning of your
code you say needs whatever I mean this
relates to the package system that we've
been talking about right this relates to
the new package system with imported
symbols exported symbols and so on right
there is some connection but we haven't
I think done a good job of drawing that
connection yet okay so we need to do
that because this is going to be related
closely to the exported symbols business
and so on because you know
we the the thing is once you've declared
that you're in a package then you know
what once a piece of code in a file says
it's in a package then it can also
qualify itself the bad case is when
you're doing things interactively you
know you've got a need somewhere far
away you know it's like the x equals
seven and then you think you then you
use X a long time later and whoops it
has value seven well and and something
is kind of related to that is we've
talked about having a namespace aliasing
major but the name space alien nature
has exactly the same problem you know
what is its scope how you know how far
does it read right I think what we've
talked about in the package system which
by the way we need to get back to as
soon as 12 hours ships is that that is
primarily dealing with files and that's
really a very lexical thing you know
it's a pre-processing step that's
actually dealing with the lexical names
of things sitting right there in the
file but it's not addressing the inter
activists you okay but but having said
all these things and we're gonna run out
of time soon um let's take a look at
these functions here and how horrifying
or not these are given we have already
done this you and I did this in May this
you know last year went through this
whole list I got a got notes in that
your ticket about to scribble down about
the changes you wanted made into all
this okay so was it was it a fairly
cosmetic set of things that had to be
done the only thing there wasn't just
cosmetic the main thing there was just
cosmetic was your desire that this
anklet expression essentially be you
know not not just a wrapper for metadata
of something but it would be more of a
wrapper for the cause be more of a
descriptor of the content of the thing
rather than just a sort of a name for a
package you know you had some desire
that can we see this document change
some of the JIRA ticket it's on the
temperature
first thing maybe these are just my
scribbled notes that I put into a ticket
for me to reheat later after that
meeting okay so this is it yeah Makka
pakka
there was some you know kind of breaking
changes in a stuff you wanted and I
thought I see ways to make this stuff
all work but I did I haven't dived in
that could be coming packard object yeah
okay so these thing like that those are
largely cosmetic kinds of things how do
you scroll this pain oh for God's sake
what did it just do you click cancel
what did I click what you you clicked it
to edit it I think it's a skull - it's
already the whole thing is shown there
there's nothing - that's it but there's
nothing left to scroll okay I think
Todd's pointed that something that you
consider cosmetic is actually a lot of
work like that let's rename to pack up
object right I mean most of the stuff is
cosmetic and not part of all some of it
with a little bit why isn't that Morris
there's one over fun
wait what was the question why is the
renaming of Pacolet - packard object so
horrifying well it's just kind of it's
probably gonna have a lot of tendrils in
a lot of places since we have to have
pull back with compatibility for
backward expressions you know it's well
we better have why do we have to do that
I don't understand why we have to do
that why is it not the case that the
packets are for one thing you wanted a
packet info file to have chocolate
object as the head right you want no no
I understand but but why isn't it the
following thing
Pacolet service sees a version 11.3
contacting it okay great it gives it
whatever 11.3 had which is frozen anyway
it sees a 12 point 1 or 12 point to
contacting it it says great I can use
the modern stuff here it is what's the
problem with that well it's just that
it's just that a packet I might release
the Packard five years ago there still
works with every version of Mathematica
and when you get install that packet
you're gonna get an old-style packet so
what so you let the in gesture accept
both I think that's what you have to do
anyway the in gesture will just say okay
great
you know if I see a Packard object I
ingest it if I see a packet I'll ingest
that too right but I'm not sure what you
mean by the in gesture the in gesture is
a packet manager and all that's code and
I am I'm saying I'm saying that you're
obviously gonna have to go through that
code and you know the front-end
ingestion in that code is got to be
dealt you know has got to handle packet
object and take those apart because
gonna have an association it's something
a little is people's the people on the
twitch chatter freaking out about that
name changed goes beyond the twist shot
that I think weekly oh god please don't
do that please please please don't
change segment sacrifice of objects that
breaks tons of user code why does it
break you thank your watch
only if you don't well if we don't keep
supporting packs I which I think we can
yes we obviously will continue to
support pack light but you know there's
people written code that says you know
if heard of you know percent you know
ahead of X tackle it then blah you know
and the head of blah is maybe going to
be packet object now for example I mean
there's going to be okay so a code that
has named these symbols in it come on
we're clearly not going to be burnt you
know we can't say you know this has
never been a documented user accessible
thing if people have used it great but
this is not something we've committed to
and it was never carefully designed you
know and it
you know it's obviously going to be
modernized in various ways so you know
we might as well I don't understand why
it's gonna break anything what why would
it break anything unless unless somebody
has their own padlet server on the
package server is really not involved at
all right
I could servers just dumb website that
serves a hacker files it's all it's all
about the code in the packet manager and
code people may have personally written
to deal with packets and remember that
personally written code may use symbols
from like dis symbol chocolate you know
from the packet manager namespace and
and that code might have to change but I
think that to the people hunting the
twitch right now I think that we can
make packet object Pacolet still work
for almost everything and people have to
get too worried about I mean ultimately
it's the the principle of you know your
code might not work with new objects but
we will continue to work with old
objects you know so if you have old
objects around we can work with them but
obviously you know you know if you know
if we don't have permission to make you
know some new style objects then we
never progress right right and we can
have I'll probably introduce a function
like packet Q or something that people
can start using that will help you know
return true for either a new or old
style pack lots of people have code
that's you know sort of manually looking
at heads they can place it with
something like that object come on okay
but I mean the rest of this stuff is it
looks like this is not particularly
other than these name changes which who
knows you know this this does not look
particularly dramatic okay
you know you know I think one big step
that needs to be done is just
progressing through some of this you
know what in a sense is grunt work and I
don't mean that to to denigrate the
people doing it because I suspect I'm
gonna be one of the people pointed to in
terms of you know first of all making
these sorts of changes and second of all
actually getting things documented yes
okay so the other thing is the exposure
of shingles from all of this stuff the
thing goes in a resource in the resource
system and then the packets I mean we
have no idea and it's I think it's more
than the exposure of shingles that's
part of it but but there's you know a
submission system which is I think going
to look modestly different from what
we've done so far yeah well I mean the
submission of the Wow somebody and the
live stream is claiming that the message
call stack has had a memory leak since
version 11 interesting interesting claim
okay um well now is the time yeah um
okay but but I'm let's just talk for a
second about the shingling stuff because
you know the good news with the function
repository is we actually have a very
clear notion of what a single shingle
should look like right we don't have I
mean this is a shingle it's very
straightforward
it's authored here and when we go to the
top of the function repository it's
gonna change but but you know
fundamentally it's going to look
something like this probably at the
level of the Pacolet repository this is
how the top-level could look but when
you go below the top level every package
is its own universe great there's no way
we can fit everything on one vertically
scrolling page no no but what I mean by
that is that the what should happen
there maybe
different kinds of things there might
for example be packets that have no
documentation and that would be
perfectly reasonable right I mean what
we really want is is a readable exposure
of the packet info file together with
whatever documentation no no no let me
say though that my thinking is that
rather than trying to accomplish
everything at once that you know we
start with a simple but really useful
subset of packets which is to say
packets which just contain Wolfram
language code sure and you know so you
know I think by confining the problem we
can get something that's out the door
sooner that's it is a sub case but it's
probably the largest subcase and it's
also the most similar to stuff we've
already done well but okay but let's
let's pull back from that for a second
okay so the main thing I'm concerned
about I mean you know people have been
arguing oh why are we doing the function
repository you know we should just do
the factor thing that's obviously wrong
because the function repository is a
clearly useful thing that it's very
well-defined that it's fairly
lightweight to contribute to and
lightweight to use the you know to me
you know just saying it's pure wolf
language code doesn't really help with
what the shingle looks like for example
it could I mean it does a little bit
because you know if it's if it's Wolfram
language code then you know that the
functionality that exposing is functions
could be a pallet that's no that's
that's why I'm defining the subset of
packets in the initial release you know
as being code only I'm not saying it
will be that way by code only you mean
you don't mean it doesn't have C code
you mean it doesn't have a pack of a
palette for example right it's basically
just functions and documentation so you
mean what about compiled compiled code
like Wolfram language
compiled code IIIi think that well I'm
as far as Wolfram language compiled code
I'm a little unclear on that because I
don't know enough about exactly I think
that's irrelevant I think it looks just
like but I am I am saying in the first
pass we exclusively sorry we in the
first pass that we that we do exclude
library link and and that's because I
want to work on getting this you know
this automated vetting system up and
running you know I you know I don't you
know as much as possible I want to avoid
human curation that maybe there's a
value-added human curation I think but
but but I don't think curation should be
a requirement for this and so I want to
get the automated stuff up and running
and and do that I think we start with
the simpler case you know where and we
solved that set of problems and then we
grow the set of problems incremental
explained so let's just understand what
our roadmap is for what we're trying to
achieve okay the first question is how
many packets do we have that are not the
internal ones that we already have a
solution for how many packets do we
think we have well I you know that could
immediately be put into the system
there's a link on the zoom cheerful let
me actually from external users a backup
repository those fires yeah so that's an
example but I mean there's no know what
the number of actual cities you took my
external one statement or no I'm talking
I'm talking about look for the function
repository we will have a solid few
hundred functions within a fairly short
time that have been got from all kinds
of different sources and and it will be
fantastic if somebody went through stack
owes well I've got a bunch of things
from there too um yeah there there's a
plan for that once we announcer fine but
but anyway I mean it's gonna have
hundreds of functions
that you know on initial release um so
my question for the packet repository is
do we similarly believe that there are a
decent number of sort of readily already
built already around but the last two
links on the zoom chat you can get an
idea there's a fair number
condoms is also a lot of data and I
could say desire to builders
this looks beautiful just like the
second link Wow
yeah well the second thing which I could
just data dog net
nice
but that's the people in a chat actually
involved in these things
Wow
cool what they need us they can just do
this themselves this is great well
they've done all the work and creme
except now they just need us to give
them a you know the tools to usually
document and and make these available
through so people can type a clear
install you know economic notice
something and then it'll work it says
you know for example people are
frustrated with the story around
documentation yes yeah and we should
definitely talk about that before this
meeting ends because there's a big piece
of effort that is not gonna be done by
me yeah has been is being launched we
are you know J is in Andres group is
gonna be working on this I mean
essentially what we're doing is there's
a me know tomorrow okay fine
are we gonna do not know with Stephen
okay people might be interested in that
I mean it's fundamentally the the
objective is to simplify dodgy tools
right we're stripping out I mean there's
just tons and tons of random junk in
here that is for very internal issues
right and we you know this is a this is
a freaking airplane cockpit this whole
thing um needs to be certified goes on
that end and in the back end - yeah I
don't know about the backend side of it
but I said what might argue we wish it
were an airplane cockpit in it then it
would be simpler anyway the at least be
a training course on how to use it right
anyway that the people have to be
recertified every so often they just
need a very basic easy-to-use
documentation tools just right by the
way when you say very basic I mean we
have you know even all this stuff with
making notes tables isn't completely
trivial spanning things and so on and so
on and that's that part is fine at that
I consider that basic that's there's
nothing wrong with that but like go and
or other for example like the big old
tab the five thousand
I mean this is crazy crazy stuff yeah
and the crazier thing is all the stuff
that's missing from here which we keep
complaining about yeah I mean you know
you can you can do I mean this is like a
this is like a I'm telling you this is
like you do anything for me you can make
a new flock you could do anything from
there there are things I want to do from
here that I can't like like write pages
for WS TP documentation is a nightmare
because there's no support from the
tooling for it you'd be happy to know
John that is actually coming soon it's
pretty high on Jays list but yes you
know the other thing that's missing here
is that docu tools is great it lets you
write offering notebooks but that does
not make built pretty versions of
notebooks and that is an entire set of
code that is divorced entirely from dock
yeah yeah the role from workbench comes
with ducky tools that are I think a
simpler version of this it does already
and I had a user asking me like well can
I not just you know break that off and
develop that by self further and I'm not
sure what to you know people using those
tools in workbench but but it's I mean I
haven't really used the tool as much and
workbench I've been a bit of an end user
of them and even as an end user it's
like you know how many button clicks
does it take to actually build the
documentation something like nine or ten
every time you want to do it or
something
but I just want to emphasize that for
example a lot of people do want to break
it out of workbench zone fine I mean
look there's a simple documentation case
for function repository and there's the
much more complex one for arbitrary
packets that involve guide pages and you
know WS TP pages and all kinds of things
like this well and by the way that's
another reason for my thinking that we
should begin simpler in scope because we
can also be simpler in scope on the
documentation side I mean I would even
suggest putting the ducky tools the
simpler version on github our github and
then get for cabal and let people line
you know it's great I mean that would be
great because then we can directly see
what users want to do and you know like
in vivo Martha sounds sounds good to me
okay we got a wrap here but but let me
just address some other comments on the
live stream here um Brian what is the
architecture for getting pattern updates
from the repository will it check for
newer versions every time Mathematica
starts period background process or
on-demand okay the answer to this is
that there is especially about auto
updates to tackle it and you know in the
past we kind of had some way which a
developer of a fact would have to jump
through some hoops but now there's an
incredibly simple way in a packet info
file you just write updating our
automatic and if you put that into your
packet after user installs it at the
moment your data and code is loaded but
before it actually loads the code it
will auto update you know look for an
update and download it and install it so
it's trivial to make a pact right now
that auto update yourself okay
will it be a simple way for users to
host their own Pacolet servers yeah will
there be a dollar Pacolet site can set
to any server I think the answer both
those questions should be yes no I mean
is reserved for our PAC website but PAC
website ad exists and that lets you add
any packets right any number of packets
right - well I don't that's necessarily
the right way to do it we might need
some cosmetic redesign for that I mean
it's like yeah it's yes that's what
we'll want I mean it's like dollar
cloudbase which will become dollar cloud
path when people can get
cloud objects from multiple cloud
servers from multiple clouds in a
certain path order
um a question if they initially supports
code only would that still allow library
link well Jonathan no no not yet but but
you know it's not that I want to leave
stuff out because I mean hey my favorite
Pacolet uses library link you know the
one that I developed but but I want to
see something shipping sooner rather
than later rather than you know waiting
months more so we can get everything
yeah
and with the way I'd like to approach
this where the the kind of Pacolet clima
cleanup of the packet functions and
symbols that would happen really before
the repository got fully underway I mean
we can do a lot of pre-work obviously
but even if the repository doesn't
support those things you could make
packets with them so our server doesn't
mean you can make make a packet right so
um someone with an unpronounceable name
here is asking about security and I you
know basically the the scheme similar to
the function repository scheme is those
things that are published in our
function repository we have vetted and
we you know have a certain as we can be
that they're not going to break security
and privacy and do crazy things with
your system if you get them from an out
in the wild packet server well that's up
to you I mean it's the same thing as any
any situation you know you've just
downloaded code from the internet do you
want to run a type thing and and and I
think another important tool for that is
you know to engage the community in that
I mean you know this is things as
inappropriate as oh yeah being able to
flag inappropriate on the other hand
being able to support you know something
like likes or upvotes or something which
is a metric of something that is you
know popular and useful yeah I mean we
talked about that in different contexts
before and I'm skeptical about that
because of the different user
communities because I think
you know something maybe a fantastic
chemistry package but there aren't as
many people doing chemistry is doing
physics for example well sure but if you
do a search for chemistry you might
still learn the most up light or maybe
the most download are the one with the
highest download counts or something
along those lines yeah yeah that point
all right well okay great um we've got
the beginning of a path here I mean I
think what's what's the next step the
way I say that the main next steps are
the Todd's work on functionality and the
work on the document so does that need
more design work Todd well no no that
meets me just to dive in and say and
we're doing this now and and it's my
intention to work with Todd on the
documentation side of things and also
after we get version 12 wraps you know I
intend to put together a larger plan for
you know what the first version of the
repository was great right and so one
thing I think we need to do we have
presumably another meeting coming up
soon for the package system and I do
want to make sure that we understand how
the package system dovetails with these
packets you know with putting things in
package yeah and I have not been in
those meetings that I should probably be
in any meeting where we start talking
about that fine we the package system I
think we at the design is fairly well
developed actually and I think now I
think it will be a good time to have one
sort of final meeting about that before
we start implementation of the package
system and to look at that cross
connection right eventually you can
imagine that the interface to the
faculty repository would create a
framework that instructs people or
directs them towards well written code
and well-structured code package system
that would involves a new vector system
well initially you're we're expecting
people to show up with it their stuff
made right I mean it's similar to the
pre-flight for the
function repository which was still um
you know which I I hope we're
progressively adding rules there that
tell people that they've got to do this
can't do that etc yes yeah I mean like
the way that we're dealing with options
and so on and that's yeah okay well
great thanks everybody um and thanks
particularly to the folks on the
livestream a lot of good comments much
appreciated and we'll try and build
something useful um okay
see y'all soon